G
POSITIVE ABOUT THAT.
>> DEMOCRATS HAD JUST PASSED
MASSIVE RESTRICTIONS ON CONCEAL
AND CARRY IN THE WAKE OF THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION TO EXPAND
THE GUN RIGHTS AND ALLOW THE
SECOND AMENDMENT TO EXIST IN
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK.
AFTER PASSING BOTH CHAMBERS IN A
SPECIAL SESSION, THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED INTO LAW BANNING CONCEAL
AND CARRY PRETTY MUCH
EVERYWHERE.
>> PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION, SUBWAY
BUSES AND COUNSELORS.
>> THIS EFFECTIVELY NEUTER'
CONCEAL AND CARRY.
AND I GUESS WE WILL GET THAT IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THE CONGRESSMAN, WE WELCOME
THEM.
>> I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
SEPARATE A LAW-ABIDING NEW
ARTICLE THAT NEEDS TO SECURELY
CARRY FIREARMS SOLELY IN
SELF-DEFENSE.
AND THAT INCLUDES THOSE AND
DOING WHAT THIS ACTION TODAY IS,
IT IS TARGETING THE LAW-ABIDING
NEW YORKER, I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE MAKING IT MORE SAFE BUT LIFS
SAFE.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS
LIKELY COUNTER RESISTANCE.
>> SO FOR PEOPLE TO PUT IT IN
LAYMAN'S TERMS, THE SECOND
AMENDMENT HAS REALLY BEEN TAKEN
AWAY THIS FROM THE CITIES NAMES
AND PLACES LIKE COURT HOUSES,
SQUARES, TIME SQUARES, COURT
HOUSES, SCHOOLS.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT THIS
INVITES ANOTHER LAWSUIT?
>> YEAH, IT'S ALMOST SPECIFICS
ALL BUT THE SUPREME COURT DID
AND THEN IN A WAY THEY RAN EVEN
WORSE THAN WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT SAID WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THEY WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS, THEY WILL
HAVE TO DECIDE AGAIN AND IT
SHOWING A LACK OF RESPECT RULE
OF LAW AND THE CONSTITUTION.
>> $35 MILLION.
SET ASIDE TO MAKE SURE THAT NEW
YORK IS A WELCOME PLACE FOR
ABORTIONS WAS ALSO PUT FORTH BY
THE GOVERNOR, TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT PLACES, SAYING THAT IT
COULD BE BANNED FOR THE MOST
PART.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THE REASON WHY THE GOVERNOR
IS PUSHING THIS AS SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT MATTERS
MOST TO NEW YORKERS.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
CRIME AND PUBLIC SAFETY OR
PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD TO
SURVIVE, WHETHER IT IS JUST THE
OVERALL COST OF LIVING SO SHE'S
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO ACTIVATE
THE BASE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
REALLY LIKE HER.
NEW YORKERS HAVE NOT HAD A GOOD
FIRST IMPRESSION.
THERE IS A LACK OF EXCITEMENT
AND ENTHUSIASM.
SO SHE'S TRYING TO PUT FEAR INTO
PEOPLE ON THE ISSUE OF ABORTION
AND DIVIDE PEOPLE.
AND SHE IS SHOWING OFF
PRO-ABORTION, AS IF IT'S A GREAT
THING THAT MORE MORE PEOPLE
SHOULD CONSIDER.
>> I UNDERSTAND, I WANT TO HEAR
THE SUGGESTION THAT YOU JUST
MADE TODAY ABOUT WHERE ABORTIONS
COULD BE TAKING PLACE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER FEDERAL FACILITIES.
VETERANS HOSPITALS, MILITARY
BASES, OTHER PLACES WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CONTROLS THE
JURISDICTION AND SOME OF THE
STATES THAT ARE HOSTILE TO
WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED TO OTHER WOMEN.
>> MILITARY BASES, IS THAT A
GOOD MOVE?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
AND IT'S REALLY SAD THAT THIS IS
SOMEONE AT THIS POINT THAT IS
DESPERATE TO GET A FOUR-YEAR
TERM AS GOVERNOR.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, YOU CAN ADVOCATE
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO ADVOCATE
FOR AND THAT IS WHY NEW YORK
LEADS THE ENTIRE POPULATION
LAWS.
YOU HAVE THESE FORMS.
YOU COULD TALK ABOUT HEALTH,
RESOURCES, COMPETENCY, PUTTING
ALL THAT ASIDE, PERHAPS ACTIVATE
YOUR BASE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THAT YOU
HAVE THE BEST SHOT OF A
REPUBLICAN.
ACTUALLY BEATING MARIO CUOMO,
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR YOU TO BE
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR KATHY
HOCHUL?
>> WE ARE ALL IN FOR THE NEXT
FOUR MONTHS, WE ARE GOING TO BE
CAMPAIGNING ACROSS THE STATE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT REPUBLICANS
AND CONSERVATIVES, INDEPENDENTS,
DEMOCRATS, DISENFRANCHISED
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT RISING ENERGY COSTS, LET'S
REVERSE THE BAN, THE ONE PARTY
DEMOCRATIC RULE.
SAYING THAT WE NEED MORE DATA
AND OH, BY THE WAY, WHEN PEOPLE
WERE ASKING HER THE QUESTION
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION, SHE SAID SHE
DOESN'T NEED ANY DATA IN ORDER
TO ACT, I SAY LET'S TALK ABOUT
ALVIN BRACKEN, BUT KATHY HOCHUL
SAYS THAT THESE CUTS LACK OF
DOING HIS JOB.
BRINGING THAT MESSAGE TO ALL.
>> REPRESENTING SUFFOLK COUNTY
FOR FOUR DIFFERE